after games former bremerton washington
high school football coach joe kennedy
would kneel and pray only with players
who voluntarily chose to participate
well when the district set new
guidelines in response to this heresy
kennedy ended his group prayers but
still engaged in post-game prayers just
by himself
well the district didn't like that
either so they put him on leave and they
won't allow him to coach
the first liberty institute filed suit
on his behalf some six years ago and in
january of this year the supreme court
finally decided to take up the case
well the court hasn't even issued its
opinion but that didn't stop the
publication sports illustrated for
alleging something far more nefarious
about coach kennedy
he's a human embodiment of a country
that's deeply divided a religious
movement that's surging with momentum
even as organized religion becomes
increasingly unpopular and most of all a
powerful right-wing machine many say is
employing a timeless division tactic us
versus them this is bad writing this
logic twisting makes the argument zero
sum and assumes that christian
nationalists have lost their rights all
to maintain a culture war strategy that
hinges on a gross oversimplification of
stakes joining me now former high school
football coach joe kennedy as well as
his attorney kelly shackleford ceo a
first liberty institute
joe that's a mouthful um not
particularly not particularly good
writing but there you have it
that that prayer
even just praying by yourself
it's such a threat to them why
i have no idea all those words it's
i don't even know what they mean i don't
even think they know what it means you
know just like in the princess bride i
don't think that means what they think
it means i was just being thankful so i
don't know what the big deal is about do
you have any regrets um do you wish you
kind of just kept it to yourself or no
no
you know i served 20 years in the marine
corps so i can exercise my rights just
like i fought for for every american and
the thought that somebody of any kind of
faith would have to hide who they are or
you know have to
you know
just be ashamed of of them being you
know a
you know anybody of faith that's just
wrong in my book kelly what happened to
sports illustrated
you know being a publication where you
can learn a lot about sports
i i think they've
wandered out of their arena and they're
in big trouble
saying that this would be a threat to
democracy
uh as you and i know uh laura
this isn't a democracy it's a
constitutional republic and we actually
value uh free speech and the free
exercise of religion which is the rights
of jeopardy here for coach kennedy so
it's bizarre and i would tell people in
case they wonder you know have any
questions about coach you know we've got
the facts you can listen to the oral
argument we've got it taped you can
listen to the oral argument the supreme
court
people can just go to first liberty.org
listen for yourself i think they'll all
back coach kennedy as most of the
country is which is why the reaction to
this was something i've never seen
before joe
what's happened to you personally i
always think of the personal stories
behind these kind of sensational attacks
on traditionalism that we've been
covering you know since this show's
inception almost five years ago now
what's happened to you
as a man as a coach as a as a
professional has inspired so many young
men over the years
yeah you know it's so difficult to
actually put it into words you know you
have something that you
love deeply and you know coaching is
something that
i mean i never knew how much those young
men would ever mean to me and then it
all of a sudden gets taken away from you
so life becomes just a big old mess and
not to mention that my wife actually
worked for the school district so you
can imagine that the hr department was
up to their eyeballs with uh coach
kennedy i i it's just been a mess and
i'm just really looking forward to the
co the courts actually just you know
ruling on the facts of the case
yeah setting setting things straight and
kelly i mean it seems to me that
joe has been damaged by this i mean
without a doubt um will he get any
monetary satisfaction by the time this
is all wrapped up
well laura he he didn't want to ask for
any money he didn't want anybody to ever
complain or say that this was about
money so he didn't seek monetary damages
he just wants the right and if he wins
which we hope he will in the next two
weeks you're going to see him back on
that field coaching those players again
and going to a knee for 20 seconds to
thank god for the privilege of coaching
them again and i think that would be the
greatest victory that coach could ever
hope for and i think it will set a great
example for the country that this is a
country that really believes in the
first amendment and we respect people's
right to pray by themselves if they want
to all right well i'd like to be there
if you get back on that field joe i'd
like to be there at that game absolutely
thank you both for being here hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else